Chúng ta sẽ quang em chỉ tấm mởi hai năm 2018,
các quang kẻ rất đường tra phối hợp với các phòng vụ của góan kính thành hoa
tống đặt quy định khởi tổ bị càng.
Tiền lệ mắt đi càng để tạm râm và khám sế châu ờ,
nơi làm việc đối với bài đối tượng tại công ty chế giảm vữ hạn thương
mại vàng bạc kinh Trung về tội trung thủy.
Trường đó, giới sự trì đạo của giảm đốc và tù trường
các quang kẻ rất đường tra về rất lập trình an đấu tranh
với các hình vì phạm pháp lật về phạm.
Bạc đặc quy trên địa bàn tình thành hoa,
lúc lượng công an đã đường và kinh chạc công ty chế giảm vữ hạn thương
mại vàng bạc kinh Trung, gọi tất là công ty kinh Trung,
để chỉ tại số hai cho mình chính lệ hoàn phương hạc thành tình thành hoa
cùng các công ty vàng bạc.
Kinh nên, là đường, lông tờ và nhiều cơ sở khác trên địa bàn phượng
hạc thành và sản nông cống.
Hàm sẽ tại công ty kinh Trung, công an đã phát hiện và thu sữa nhiều miếng
kinh lại mọi vàng cùng các dây tờ,
tại điều khác có liên quan đến việc kinh xanh của công ty và hình vì chủ tối.
Tối năm 2018 đến nay, ông ấy hiểu bình,
sinh năm 2019, chú phương hạc thành,
giảm đốc công ty kinh Trung và vợ là bà lế thì thu hương,
sinh năm 2019, cũng nghĩ người có vây trò làm chủ đã chỉ đạo các nghiên triệu
tệ hoàn cá nhân để thực hiện rất dịch 1 bán vàng nhằm một đích chủ nối,
bỏ ngoài sổ sách tuy nhập của công ty, với thị thải lớn cho nhận nước.
Thông kênh xanh thu của công ty trong năm 2018,
2018 đến 2018, lên tới năm 2019, nhưng mỗi thằng chỉ lột tối cho nhận nước sắp xì mới chự động.
Bình và hông đã chỉ đạo là khoảng chủ tệ hoàn cá nhân,
đện ngoài sổ sách không hay bảo với các quan thử,
chỉ tính riêng một tệ hoàn của những viên trên tiền hông bởi tã ngăn hàng bia đi vì.
Trong hai tháng 12, 2020, hai chiến hàng nghị khu chăm tham i tư đã thực hiện các xa dịch lên tới
1 trong 2018, chúng tôi gần năm 2018, chúng tôi gần năm 2018.
Thức hiện hàng viên chúng tôi này có sự đồng phạm giúp xúc xức của các thình viên khác,
là con cháo trong gia đình ông bình trong đó có nguyễn thu ngà,
sinh năm 2019, chú phương hạc thành.
Căn kỳ cơ cơ thể lựa đá thú thập được,
các quan kỳ rất đều trạc công an tình thành hoàn đã giá quy định khuề tổ bộ sung của ánh hình sự chốn thế.
Đồng thời, giá quy định khuề tổ bi Khanh và thị hành lệ mắt đi cân để tạm ra,
khám sẽ châu Ân, nơi làm việc bởi với vấn vĩnh hiểu mình,
là thì thu hương vấn vấn tu ngà về tổ chốn thế.
Hịt, các quan kỳ rất đều trạc đang tiếp tục đều trạm một giọc để xử liên nghiêm hình vi của các cá nhân,
tôi chức có lý quan.